hey everybody welcome back to XI Kura in
today's episode I'm going to try my hand
at building the station building as well
as some of the surrounding area with
foliage and some Persian inspired
gardens now all of this is kind of
experimental both because there are
themes that I'm not really very used to
or experienced with but also because I'm
trying to use the new pieces that we got
in the 1.7 update and the vintage DLC as
much as I can to see like what kind of
different themes can we really get into
with these pieces so yeah the first
thing that I'm starting off with here is
the station building which is really a
test for these new building pieces
especially the ones which I thought look
really Islamic because Islamic
architecture is something that I haven't
done so much but which I really thought
would be very easy to do with these new
pieces and something which we really
didn't have any scenery pieces for
before and even though we didn't get an
entire tile set or theme of these pieces
there are just a few objects which make
this theme so much more viable and
planet coaster and these are just a few
objects that I'm trying to test as much
as possible with this station building
so first off we've got the pillars on
the bottom there which kind of do look a
lot like the pillars that we had in the
game so far you might say but they're
actually slightly different in a sense
that they are more wide at the base than
they are at the top of the pillar which
is a type of pillar that we didn't
really have so far all of the ones that
we had you could sort of extend yourself
but these ones work a little bit better
as the smaller pillars I think since
traditionally a lot of classical
architecture uses pillars that are
slightly wider at the base than they are
at the top kind of as an effect of force
perspective to make the pillars seem a
little bit larger than they actually are
and having that kind of shape in a
pillar in planet coaster is actually
handy to get that sort of architecture
done we also got some new tops for these
pillars which helps the variation and
finally you might notice those arches
that I placed on top of them which have
a look which is probably very distinct
the Arabian to a lot of Western people
they're often referred to as horseshoe
arches since they used to have a round
top which kind of made them look like a
horseshoe because they kind of curved
inward more from the pillar but these
ones actually have the pointy bits on
top more like a gothic arch but all of
that just kind of helps to get a more
Islamic architecture style look to these
see yeah I actually really love these
these little objects and even with just
a few objects of new arches and new
pillars there's so much more variation
that you can create in your buildings
and there's definitely a lot more
options for Islamic architecture now the
next thing that I wanted to try on the
side here is to build a minaret
obviously because that's something
pretty typical of Islamic architecture
as well and really I didn't use too many
new pieces some of this you could
already do but especially on the roof I
decided to test some of the new pieces
for their decorative purposes and I
ended up using a lot of planters which
came new in this update to create the
and the spire of the minarets which
actually worked out quite well it took a
little bit of trial and error to see
what planters would actually fit well
together but in the end it creates a
very narrow sort of slender aspired top
with a bunch of detail which you
couldn't really get if you were to build
this little spire out of tiny wooden
posts or any other way of creating an
entirely yourself so yeah I'm actually
quite happy with how the building turned
out so far for a while I was also
planning to have one big tower on the
side there which is why there's a
floating pavilion I really wanted to
force myself to use that piece since I
think it's one of the more easy to use
and really useful pieces in the updates
but in the end I really didn't see a
tower fits in there so I decided to
remove that but it's like it's a great
piece nonetheless I really like it
in any case I feel like we're this far
into the station building then I should
give a bit of an explanation on what I'm
trying to do exactly here partly because
I'm
that experienced with Islamic
architecture so I really had to learn a
bunch of stuff and look up a bunch of
pictures to try and get this as much
rights as I could just to make sure that
I didn't build some weird unrealistic
concoction of well a mixture of styles
that wouldn't really make sense so what
I'm going for here essentially is the
indo-saracenic style which was very much
used in India and Malaysia under the
times of British colonization and it's a
style that's very similar to other
Islamic architecture styles there's a
lot of overlap between the Islamic
architecture the indo-saracenic and the
Moorish architecture that kind of stuff
but this one is kind of special because
it it is used for a lot of really
important buildings in South Asia stuff
like mosques but also government
buildings or even real way stations one
of my biggest inspirations and one of my
favorite buildings in this style is the
Kuala Lumpur railway station so it's got
that going for it but it was also mostly
used by European architects as far as
I've seen it was kind of Britain's way
to establish their dominance as an
empire but at the same time kind of show
their appreciation for traditional
Indian architecture but it also mixed a
lot of elements from Moorish
architecture and even gothic and
classical so it's really kind of
eclectic as was very popular in that
period in any case that's about as much
as I can summarize it before I get into
crazy inaccuracies most likely I just
found it a really interesting style to
use for this coaster I think it would be
more interesting and more doable than a
traditional Islamic architecture to go
for a revival style which is more of a
mixture of styles just to I could throw
a bunch of stuff on the building without
making it too inaccurate besides this is
a theme park so I really shouldn't worry
so much about historical accuracy or
really anything like that but the great
thing about the theme is that it does
have the signature elements of the
minarets and the horseshoe arches
and all of that good stuff so it was a
good time to try this so you might at
this point see some of the similarities
to some buildings like the Taj Mahal and
stuff like that which is mostly results
of this style I also drew some influence
from one of the major mosques in
Malaysia which has some black horizontal
stripes across the building which you
see in more of this Arab or Moorish
architecture and I thought it would be
nice to add some detailing to the
building
not to mention make it a little bit less
white because with so many very whites
and light elements I thought it was
sticking out from the coaster a little
bit too much I was already really
worried that this this whole decorated
station wouldn't really fit the
otherwise quite modern and minimalistic
coaster but really the surroundings of
the station kind of fixed that issue for
me but I shouldn't spoil all the later
parts of this video yes you'll see what
I mean when we get into the Persian
garden section for now I am just trying
to finish the station as much as I can
what I haven't talked about yet is the
onion dome up top which is really a very
characteristic elements of Islamic
architecture as well especially these
really large onion domes because even
though we see onion domes quite a bit in
European architecture as well they're
usually much smaller the only thing I
really have to say about this dome is
that it's maybe a little bit on the fat
side
King r63 already pointed this out in the
comments of the last video this dome is
is really really flat most of the domes
on buildings like this are much more
vertical and I don't know if this dome
was built and was based on a particular
building or anything like that but I
think you know from now on I'm probably
gonna make my own domes but then again
that's what I was always gonna do
eventually anyway the same kind of goes
for the spires plus the dome does work
well enough for this building and I
think it looks pretty neat on it I feel
like a larger dome that would be more
taller would kind of look too large for
the building itself so I think it works
out but it's definitely something that
stuck out to me as well in any case at
this point I was kind of
with the the path layouts and I decided
to leave this footage in because it is
actually where I built some of the
signature parts of the path but at the
same time I was kind of struggling with
some stuff like I wanted to use the new
planter pieces as path covers which
actually worked really well I really
loved the varying lights sort of
tropical looking brick texture of it I
think it goes really well with the theme
and it goes super well with the palm
tree textures but at the same time I was
kind of struggling with what kind of
layouts I wanted my parts to have at
this point I was really just still going
for a generic path layouts just kind of
around the coaster not so much to lay
the focus on the paths themselves but
just kind of to have an area to take
pictures of the coaster from but at some
points during this whole triangle stuff
that is going on there I figured this
path layout wouldn't really work out so
well it doesn't really fit the theme it
doesn't really look that great and
there's definitely some things that
could be improved upon it not to mention
that it kind of ends really awkwardly on
the left the part just kind of stops and
I didn't really know what to do with
that part so over here I decided let's
just redo everything remove this whole
section and try to make this into a
thematically more appropriate Persian
garden and a straight away I have to say
I'm not that experienced with these not
to mention that a lot of the scenery
elements are kind of missing to make
this come to life really well so this is
an inspiration on a person garden more
than an actual realistic Persian garden
because it's still missing a lots to be
historically accurate in anyway but it
still bears very similar layouts and an
idea behind it so Persian gardens are
very typically quite geometrical and
they'll really have very pronounced
middle where they'll usually have a
fountain of sorts and sometimes they'll
have four rivers kind of branching out
from the fountain completely straight to
the different parts of the garden that
kind of divides the gardens into four
quarters and I decided to do a very
similar kind of
thing here with the building as well you
probably know it at this point as the
main weenie of the garden these types of
gardens do typically also have these
buildings or some kind of focus focal
points at the end to look at but in this
case the station pretty much perfectly
fulfills that role and then to the sites
are all the areas the planters if you
will where all of the flowers and the
bushes and the trees are going to be
located and there's the real reason why
I wanted to try this type of garden
because it not only kind of thematically
works with the theme of this station but
it's also really handy to try out the
new pieces of the updates which as you
might have noticed I've already added
some bushes in the middle there which
looked different from the bushes that we
have in the game so far there are these
rose bushes that I'm placing on the side
of there on the side of the palm trees
there and then there's all kinds of
different flowers that I'm using
throughout the garden and I basically
just kind of forced myself to use all of
the flowers except for the sunflowers
which I think would really fit so well
into the garden but I really wanted to
use all of them just to try and test
them as much as I could and I have to
say I am actually really really glad
that they decided to add these flowers
into the game really this update is
probably my favorite so far because
there's so many so many sets of just a
few objects which just add so much to
the game we've got the custom supports
now new path elements which are really
great like these types of lanterns are
something that I feel like we've been
knitting for quite a while now and then
there's all of the new building elements
which you can use for so many themes and
I think the flowers are just one part of
that and one reason why I especially
love these flowers is that you can
recolor just about every single thing
about them so you can not only recolor
the color of the flowers themselves you
can even recolor the leaves and so
that's how I got the bushes in the
middle there they're technically flower
bushes but I just decided to make
everything everything green in a shade
that I was kind of looking for there
which makes them look much more like a
bush and I think that makes these
flowers super super flexible you can
basically create flower beds with any
kind of color combination that you want
and you can even use them as new bushes
and I think they come they combine
really well with the existing trees and
the existing bushes as well so it's just
all together pretty great time I'm
really happy that we've got this new
foliage if there's only one thing on my
wish list that I could still nudge into
this video it's may be new trees because
those things are getting a little bit
limited but that said I think for this
theme it's not too bad
since a lot of the adventure foliage can
also be used for this theme a lot of the
tropical looking trees as well as the
palm trees and all of that stuff so for
this theme it's not too limited but I
think especially for European themes for
instance the amount of trees that we
could use it's still a little bit on the
low side speaking of which I'm just
adding a very simple tree line here on
the side just kind of copy and pasted
from one of my earlier builds and then
filled in with some extra trees because
to be honest this is just still a very
small project and trying to not let this
suck up my time then I put in my other
stuff and I just cut some corners here
and there speaking of cutting corners I
I've seen and I agree with a lot of the
critiques about the coaster layout there
are definitely some parts where it could
be a little bit smoother and the first
curve going into the first hill is a
little bit over banked some of the banks
airtime Hills are also a little bit to
smooth it out when it comes to the
banking but honestly those are just
little issues that I don't want to put
time into fixing because I think they're
they you only really noticed them when
you pay attention to it and fixing all
of those really small issues is gonna
cost a lot of time and I really just
want to keep cutting some corners and
try to finish this whole series in three
episodes in total which hopefully should
be doable I think it will be
so yeah that's really all that I'm gonna
say about this series this is not
intended to be a series like Jaeger horn
or anything like that just a quick test
of the new pieces and trying to already
kind of break the mould on how you can
use them and just leave it at that we'll
see where we go with these new pieces
from here on out so finally it is time
to finish up the exit of the station
I'll get to the entrance and the queue
at some later stage and at the very end
I'm just adding a lot of crunch robbery
and Rock work here to finish it all up
and I think this is another example of
how you really shouldn't judge your
buildings before you put foliage around
the MCUs foliage can really make a world
of difference I was to be honest really
skeptical about this station building
for pretty much the entire recording
until I started adding all of this
foliage around it I think with all of
the bushes and everything it works out
decently and it doesn't really stick out
anymore
not to mention then it kind of actually
fits the theme of the rollercoaster I
sort of just yolo'd this whole theme I
didn't really expect much out of an
intimate mega lights themed to Islamic
architecture because truth be told I
really just wanted to try the supports
and try the Islamic architecture
elements that we got in the new updates
but actually work pretty well together
I also a trick li slightly changed the
color of the track and live in the
middle of this episode to a slightly
more pink issue at which point I think
it is now definitely pink and not any
more rights in the middle between pink
and red so yeah I think that's a little
bit more needs I think the red coaster
track is kind of an overused color
scheme and we need more pink coasters in
this world in any case I'm just trying
to finish this up with all of these
flower beds
there's not really a sound of a logic to
the flowers that I chose or to the
colors that I chose it probably could
have been a little bit more well thought
out but I think it works well enough for
the test that it is and for me it's
definitely proven that these flowers are
gonna stand the test of time and that
they actually mix in quite well with the
phone
that we have in the game so far so yeah
I'm quite happy with them only thing
that I really couldn't use them for is
for some of this remaining foliage
underneath the coaster where there's
just sort of a ruined grass texture and
some sand and mud and then some little
bits of grass and small shrubs here and
there which is just a sort of ground
texture that I want to try and use
because it's more interesting to look at
than a completely empty ground but it's
really just kind of a mess it's not
really planted or anything like that
it's just trying to look like the end
result of not caring for your ground and
just letting all the wheat grow for a
few years in any case that's it for this
episode so I want to thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]